may 2004 the moment marked across
europe for the ten nations joining the
eu and a defining moment in the
evolution of a union which
since its inception after world war ii
has changed constantly
this though was largely the moment the
eu went east embracing former soviet and
soviet satellite countries
freed of communism more than a decade
before the main thing for
us joining eo in 2004 was
returning back to the european family
and it's worked
if you compare living standards you can
see a difference clearly
10 years ago the support for eu
membership was
67 now it is
80 the rise may in part be down to big
neighbor russia's activities
in and around ukraine and the sense of
security
that membership of the eu not to mention
nato brings
it is a breach of international law we
have quite a fresh expertise
on on russia and the russians and this
expertise is
at the disposal of our allies there's
been a swing in favor of the eu too
in poland among the most skeptical
during pre-accession negotiations
but that has largely evaporated as
trading opportunities and living
standards have risen
enlargement also went south to the small
mediterranean island nations of malta
and cyprus
ten years on many previous eu doubters
are satisfied
but they want more the issue of
migration is
an issue where we are fighting very hard
there is an understanding and in fact
we've had
a number of positive results but we
still think the eu is not doing enough
who knows where the eu will stand after
the next 10 years
bigger or conceivably smaller for the
moment the skies continue to light up
for an eu club membership
apparently worth the years of hard talk